[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
wednesday august 10th
i'm zoe thomas for the wall street
journal
during the pandemic demand for software
e-commerce video games and pretty much
anything with the word crypto in it went
into overdrive
that led tech companies to hire new
workers at a rapid clip
but now times are changing
high inflation and continued supply
chain disruptions are causing economic
growth to slow and taking hiring with it
in just the last few months crypto
exchange coinbase let go of 18 of its
workforce tesla laid off 200 people
netflix said it was cutting three
percent of its staff
and companies like google parent
alphabet amazon and facebook parent meta
have all said they will slow their
hiring plans
not to mention the cuts happening at
startups
so is this a sign of doom for the tech
labor market
my guest today says maybe not
zeta howard is a partner and the chief
talent officer for venture capital firm
ivp
the firm has invested in companies like
dropbox github and snap and its current
portfolio includes discord and grammarly
hi sata thanks for joining me thank you
happy to be here
so start off by telling me a little bit
about what your role is
so my role at ivp is to help our
portfolio companies with all things
related to
talent human capital essentially the
people in their organization sometimes
it's around helping them recruit in
senior level executives sometimes it's
around figuring out how to face a
worldwide pandemic sometimes it's about
thinking about returned office
strategies hiring strategies in general
but basically anything related to
their employees
i want to talk about a few of those
things that you just mentioned because
the the landscape for hiring in tech
right now is is changing we're hearing
about a lot of layoffs and hiring
freezes you know from your perspective
what does that say about kind of where
the industry is right now
so i think the interesting thing to note
about that is that this is i think very
different than layoffs hiring freezes
from the past
i would call this strategic cuts
strategic freeze versus what we saw back
in 2001 2000 with the technology and the
dot-com bust where it was very desperate
companies were going out of business
they were no longer going to exist if
they didn't make some of these cuts or
even if you think about 2008 and 2009
the worldwide financial meltdown this is
very different in that companies
throughout this year throughout 2022
have been looking at their runway for
the future and thinking about how do we
preserve the cash that we've raised over
the past two to three years and so
they're making very difficult decisions
around the people their organization
they're maybe looking at new initiatives
that they started that aren't going to
be successful and cutting those
initiatives they're thinking much more
critically around growth i think in the
last few years it's been growth and
growth at all costs which meant hiring
as many people as you could for whatever
salaries you could get them at the same
time i think it's important to note that
even while companies are making cuts or
maybe putting on freezes there are still
key roles that they're hiring for and
there are still jobs to be had within
the technology landscape
what's behind that pullback though why
does tech in particular find itself in
this place i think tech in particular
finds itself in this place because the
growth has just been so astronomical
throughout the pandemic if you think
about how many people had heard the word
zoom and knew what zoom was in january
of 2020 we did as an organization we
were using zoom for meetings etc not to
the extent that we are now versus august
of 2020 it's a verb now it's it's
commonplace everything that we do and
that filters through technology in all
different sorts of ways you've got to
think about how you protect your
organization from a security standpoint
you've got to think about how you're
working together from a collaboration
standpoint and so many different ways
and so many different touch points
technology has really benefited frankly
from the pandemic in ways that were
unforeseen before and that doesn't go on
forever so i think because the highs
were so high it feels like the lows are
so lows when what is normal which is
things slow down and the come back down
is happening okay but it it seems like
kind of because these highs have have
been so high we're hearing a lot of ceos
say you know we over hired we extended
ourselves too much
to an extent you hear something like
that and you think like well as an
employee that's that's not my fault that
sounds like bad management you know and
yet the individuals kind of end up
having to deal with those repercussions
exactly individuals do end up having to
deal with the repercussions i think it's
easy to say it's bad management and i
think with some companies that's
certainly a part of it it's also no one
can really predict the future with all
certainty there are certainly ceos that
have done a
better job of understanding their
marketplace and maybe
for good or for bad or more conservative
in their growth strategies were more
conservative and how they were bringing
people on and how many but they were
also maybe missing part of the market
and part of market share that they
should have been getting and could have
been getting but now when they look back
they maybe seem smarter in this
particular moment because they're making
fewer cuts and then there were those
that were very aggressive that were
maybe doing better raising money at
higher evaluations growing even faster
that have to make even bigger swings the
other way because of that it's it's hard
you know hindsight is absolutely 20 20
on these types of things and it's hard
to say right wrong i think the other
thing to remember is
it isn't over right this is just a point
in time this is a marker and if you did
that marker for every single company
there was a time where they were at a
high there were a time where they were
maybe at a low or at a medium the
conversation still continues but you're
absolutely right employees are the one
that end up bearing the brunt of these
things
i want to ask you about something that
feels a little unique to the situation
we have at the moment and you're seeing
these big tech companies ceos come out
and say things like you know if you're
not good enough then maybe you should
decide to leave our startups and smaller
companies taking that kind of approach
to and what does that do to the market
that is a great question and i can tell
you
in talking to some of our portfolio ceos
i have not heard that sort of
positioning i have not heard that
statement around if you're not good
enough et cetera and this is just my
personal opinion i think with maybe some
of the larger companies because when you
get to 10 000 employees etc there is a
little bit more of an ability to ride
the coattails and hide maybe in certain
areas and maybe you don't have to to be
at that top ten percent top five percent
all the time there's a there's a larger
bell curve if you will when you're at a
smaller startup when you're at 200
employees when you're one of
five customer success reps not even just
there's no place to hide but there's so
much work to be done with fewer
resources that you really are
most of the time operating at such a
high level i don't know if it makes
sense in the same way
all right that was sada howard chief
talent officer for ivp
thanks for joining us thank you happy to
be here
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you want more tech stories
check out our website wsj.com
and if you like our show please rate and
review it you can do that wherever you
get your podcasts
i'm zoe thomas for the wall street
journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
you